this is the front line in the as yet
undeclared war between ukraine and
russia few foreign policy issues are
more pressing for the biden
administration than this the u.s
supports the government in kiev and says
russia has a choice there is the path of
diplomacy and dialogue to try to resolve
whatever differences there are uh
peacefully through diplomacy clearly the
preferable path clearly the most
responsible path and the one that we
would prefer
but there is also the the path if russia
chooses to renew aggression
of confrontation and consequences
for russia and we have been working
to build out both of those paths in very
close coordination and collaboration
with uh with allies and partners
one of those main allies and partners is
germany whose new chancellor olaf schatz
has stressed the importance of the
transatlantic relationship it's a view
some analysts say is mirrored in
washington so the united states is
making every effort to keep europe in
the loop
there was going to be no discussion of
the ukraine without ukrainians involved
no discussion of european security
architecture without europeans involved
so that is
surely going to be the guiding principle
of the united states
it's no secret that many european
leaders welcomed the result of the 2020
u.s election
nor that they had high hopes for a biden
administration something the man himself
made very clear to everyone first of all
i'm letting him know that america is
back
we're going to be back in the game it's
not american alone
in the last years of the trump
administration many in germany felt that
the former president had eroded his
country's supposed moral authority
some here in germany even began
referring to angela merkel as the leader
of the free world
now both of them are out of office
and opinion pollsters say the german
public feels very differently almost 8
out of 10 germans who said that the
relations are good or very good and also
the united states
is now perceived by 44 of germans as the
most important partner for germany
but how long that perception lasts may
depend in part on how the west deals
with the ukraine crisis
remembering that right now joe biden's
government says russia has many tens of
thousands of troops massed on ukraine's
borders dominic kane al jazeera berlin